d'abord comme le site de la continuité
d'une action et d'une volonté qui a
commencé au moment de la révolution
française et qui a toujours conduit à la
recherche des principes que la
déclaration universelle des droits de
l'homme et du citoyen avait fait sienne
2-1 à versailles et je dois dire que
cette continuité dans ces lieux elle a
été incarnée notamment par un certain
nombre d'hommes je pense bien sûr à
l'abbé grégoire
je pense à victor schoelcher je pense
aussi à gaston monnerville qui a été un
de mes très glorieux prédécesseurs et
qui était lui même petit fils d'esclave
et c'est un peu le symbole de cette
république d'une république qui ne
transige jamais sur les valeurs mais une
république qui dans ce jardin veut aussi
que nous trouvions l'apaisement dans une
amende et une société nous l'avons vu
dans le débat récent de l'élection
présidentielle trop souvent déchirés en
désarroi et ce désarroi cette déchirure
nous ne pouvons pas ne pas l'oublier
nous qui avons des responsabilités
politiques
et ce matin c'est un temps de mémoire
c'est aussi un temps on se positionne
sur l'essentiel des valeurs que nous
avons en partage dans la république et
ça a été dit par vous-même gérard
larcher et par le président de la
république dont vous avez salué la
présence fidèle à cette cérémonie
depuis cinq ans présence fidèle et aussi
j'ai eu l'occasion
même si nous avons eu parfois des
divergences de dire que quand les
moments est essentiel que nous
retrouvions
c'est aussi l'image d'une assemblée qui
est une assemblée ici qui a un rôle de
balancier stabilisateur mais vous le
savez de défense essentielle de la
liberté individuelle et collective et ça
devient d'une liberté dont on parlait ce
matin d'une liberté à la fois
individuelle et collective et c'est un
combat d'hier d'aujourd'hui et de demain
voilà pourquoi j'ai voulu aussi citer un
certain nombre de désordres du monde que
connaît bien liens de zazou et je
voudrais profiter de ce moment pour
saluer son action à la fondation mais
aussi son action comme éclaireur
notamment des défis que nous avons à
relever la france l'europe avec le
continent africain